I want to congratulate you we know each
other well you've been on the show many
times toured with you last year we had a
blast and I got to know your girlfriend
at the time Christina and now she is
your my fianc your fiancee you should do
you should get married in this just be
holding a crystal or boy you get married
you know it'll just confuse everyone I
love it I'll be in I had to lock her up
you know like you said she um
she's a beautiful one she's really nice
oh she likes you a lot the last time we
saw you you she gave you a big hug and
the way she responded I was just like I
better lock her oh really you thought
that there was a she was liking her her
hug with Conan
well she talked about it for a rest of
the day oh all right then okay that's
good for me I've been married so long I
don't know I don't hug a woman and I
just think they're tolerating it
[Laughter]
including my wife well I mean clearly
she's got weird taste
yeah well that's all the time we have
you like um she told me one time we were
hanging out and she told me that she her
whole life growing up she had a crush on
David Spade David Spade yeah okay yeah I
don't know David a long time I'm not
gonna say that's preposterous I don't
get it I don't understand I'm talking
like the threats supposed to be bigger
stronger you know not Ellen's older
sister well also to she obviously has a
type me and David Spade yeah yeah so Wow
okay so because you felt threatened in
that moment that she hugged me and
because she has a crush on David Spade
you decided I must lock this up yeah
yeah let her go away
okay well that's exciting David Spade is
easily obtainable for her
so am I